[موسيقى]
بقلوبنا مؤمنه بقضاء الله وقدره تنعى شبكه
العربيه والعربيه الحدث الزميل الاعلاميه
نجوى قاسم التي وافتها المنيه صباح اليوم
في منزلها في دبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لم يكن الثاني من يناير 2020 يوما سهلا
على كل العاملين في قناتي العربيه والحدث
حيث استيقظنا على فاجعه فقد سيده الحوار
السياسي في العالم العربي الزميل العزيزه
نجوى قاسم لحظات توقفت وساعات تباطاتت
وايام بدت شاحبه في ملامح محبي نجوى من
المحيطي الى الخليج لكن الحزن الكبير
يومها لم يمنعنا من ان نواصل مسيرتها
الطويله في العربيه والحدث بتكريمها حتى
اخر لحظاتها على هذه الارض ولنجوى نقول
انت باقيه فينا مثل زهر البيلسان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نشراتنا الاخباريه من قناه العربيه
كان عندهم مشكل اكبر مع اسرائيل هذه واضحه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
على الاقل ثلاثه من العاملين في المحطه
لاول مره بتوه على فكره انه ايه في شخص
هلا انت كنت عم تتحدث معه وبعد لحظه مات
وبعد لحظه مات
[موسيقى]